bien monsieur déjà du trafic sur ces
images tournées le 21 avril dernier par
son épouse
on aperçoit une altercation entre adil
sefrioui au fond et un homme de 72 ans
qui aurait photographié sa maison très
rapidement le ton monte l'homme profère
des insultes racistes
il monte dans sa voiture et fauche alors
violemment adil sefrioui
je suis dans l'incompréhension
aujourd'hui qu'on fait parce que depuis
mercredi dernier
ça fait déjà une semaine et puis me
suivront liberté depuis le jour des
faits il était mis en liberté
et ça ça me pose beaucoup de questions
et je me sent en insécurité
franchement moi je me sens je me sens
pas humain quoi le prévenu reconnaît les
faits mais la défense justifie la
décision de le laisser libre sous
contrôle judiciaire
le substitut du procureur madame royer a
jugé qu'il n'y avait que cet élément
moral de l'intention manquer si vous
voulez tout simplement et que
visiblement mon client n'avait pas
l'intention de passer physiquement à
l'acte dans cette affaire il est en
légitime défense
il vient se défendre et si c'est ce qui
sera plaidée à l'audience du 28 mai
prochain devant le tribunal une défense
inacceptable pour l'avocate d'adil
sefrioui qui envisage de demander une
requalification des faits dans
l'instrument vidéo fait très
sérieusement penser à une tentative
d'assassinât faut être clair je suis
extrêmement surpris de cette personne
n'ait pas fait l'objet d'une ouverture
d'instruction extrêmement surpris que
cette personne n'ait pas été placé en
détention
très clairement qu'ils s'étaient
monsieur cyfra wii qui avait été à la
place de cette personne
je suis convaincu je suis convaincu que
monsieur sefra oui aurait été interpellé
très rapidement et qu'il aurait sans
aucun doute été placé en détention
l'homme incriminé sans antécédent
judiciaire et convoqués fin mai au
tribunal de dole pour violences
aggravées et injures racistes